くねくね笑動物
イェェェ～イ
マネしちゃう、笑っちゃう、叫んじゃう
なんとも迷惑な商品がありますね
はいというわけで
以前ですね喋った事を真似するぬいぐるみみたいなやつを
紹介したんですけども
たくさん並べると大連鎖が起きました
それのなんか進化版かどうかわかんないんですけども
こいつはマネするだけじゃなくて
笑ったり叫んだりするらしいです
ね！あれすごかったすよね
だって普通に多分こんにちはって言ったら
こんにちはって返しつつも
ハハハハハハハハハ
いやーーーーーーーーーー！
とかいうのかも知れませんね
ま、ホントかどうかわかんないですけど
とりあえず一体ちょっと開けてみましょう
はい、こちらです
まぁ見た感じそんな悪い気がしませんね
結構普通のぬいぐるみっぽい感じです
よし、出来ました！
(よし、できました）
おっ！
なんかなんか前回より動きがないですね
あっこんにちは
あ、いやいやいやいやそんなめっそうもありません
ちゃんと友達準備しときましたよ
あっは、そんなそんなそんな恐れ多いっす先輩
なんか笑ったり爆笑したりしませんね
なんかモードがあるんかな？
あ！なるほどですね！真ん中のここを押したら
モードが変わるみたいです
あっ分かりました、押させていただきます！失礼します！
さぁモードが変わりました
ぇえ！？
なんか馬鹿にされてる感すごいんだけど
リピートしてくるようになっちゃった
(リピートしてくるようになっちゃった)
(はーはっはっはっはっはー)
おまえなー
そう喜ぶなや
はい、というわけですごい笑いモードにすると
なんかリピートしたり色々変化があるんですけども
今回この子の仲間を
沢山準備いたしました
なんか結構売れてるのかわからないですけど
種類がとても少なかったです
あーすいません、ありがとうございます親分
あー、分かりました開封します！
おーすごい可愛いこいつは！
なんか無駄にブタが多いんですけど結構種類がなくて
探すのがすごい大変でした
ウーパールーパーも可愛いですね
なんか見た目がいいぞ今回
カワウソがめちゃくちゃ可愛い
カワウソがすごい多分一番売れてるんでしょうね
はい、というわけで全員出ました！
ちょっとなんかピンク感がつよいんですけども
なんか買えるぶんだけ片っ端から買ったら
この量になりました
はい、というわけでようやく電池をすべて入れ終わりました
これどうなんだろうね
結局笑うモード押さないと
発狂とか笑ったりしないんで
普通にオンしただけだと
なるほど、なるほど
はい
あー、ありがとうございます
あー、ありがとうございます、頑張ります～
ここからは音をたてると終わりです
ではつけていきましょう
お前らー
静かにーせーーーーい
(お前らー)
(静かにー)
(せーーーーい)
はいと言わけでこれが前やったのと同じモード
普通に僕が喋ったことを真似するだけのモードなんですけども
あーあーあーありがとね、はいはいはい
爆笑絶叫モードがあるんで
それにちょっとチェンジさせようと思います
ここ押していきます
よし、どうだ
ぁあん？
は？
というお笑いモードに変えても多分さっきの連鎖がとまんないんで
今度は電源つけて
すぐお笑いモードに変えて静かに置きましょう
行きます
むげ～んだ～いなぁゆ～めの～あとの～
(むげ～んだ～いなぁゆ～めの～あとの～)
ほう！
いぇぇぇぇぇぇぇい
あー！お前ー！
あはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっはっ
バカにしてんのかぁ！？
これあれだな
笑いモードにしたらただただ
煽りのパワー強くなるだけですね
このシリーズはたくさん買う事は
ただただカオスを生むだけという事が今回分かりました
今日もご視聴
ありがとうございました！
えぇ！？
(えぇ！？)
あれ！？
(あれ！？)
お前ら！
(お前ら！)
完璧！？
(完璧！？)